if h5 queen g8 up keep check it's force  checkmate there's nothing that black can  do and that would be a checkmate  wow let's see  no move yet no move played by ben oh  he's got a minute come on veggie oh and  he's not streaming so we can't see oh  oh no uh it's gonna be this exact  checkmate it's gonna be the checkmate  here comes sodor sees it no question  he's going  to do this mate oh boy  oh boy oh oh oh the queen  oh my gosh oh my gosh he blunted the  queen does benji see it does benji see  it benji do you see this oh he has to  see it look at benji's face he's in  shock  oh he took the queen and sardoch loses  the queen  becky is so confused he's smiling  no the tragedy not the queen  oh oh my god benji is smiling  sardosha's melting he's melting